Guten Tag, mein Name ist Doan. Ich bin heute der Diensthabenderarzt und würde jetzt gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Ja, bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Jürgen Kotwetz.
Jürgen Kotwetz.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
J.W. Julia, mein Vornamen. J.W. Julia Ü. Ü. R.G.E.N. Und Nachname Kaufmann K.O.T.W.E.Z.
Wie oder wer? V.
Wer.
Okay. Herr Kotwetz.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Geboren am 22.06.1980.
Okay. Herr Kotwetz, entschuldigen Sie. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ein sehr langer Mann. 1,91 Meter groß.
Okay. Und wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Mein letzter Gewicht ist ungefähr 95 Kilo, Herr Doktor.
95 Kilo, okay.
Ich bin alt, aber ich bin adipos.
Nein, es sieht so aus, dass Sie wahrscheinlich nur mal Gewicht sind, aber das muss ich berechnen. Okay?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Danke schön.
Okay. Was führt Sie heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe einen Bauchschmerzen.
Bauchschmerzen. Okay. Ja. Seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Herr Doktor, gestern Abend habe ich eine Funke Pizza gegessen. Nach dem Verstehen habe ich eine sehr oder nicht sehr, aber starke Bauchschmerzen.
Oberbauch, ja.
Sofort nach dem Essen oder erst heute ein bisschen?
Ja, ich habe eine Funke Pizza gegessen nach dem Essen und habe seit gestern Abend Bauchschmerzen gehabt.
Und auch gestern Abend habe ich zwei Tassen Koffe getrunken.
Ja. Sie haben Pizza gegessen, danach einen Kaffee, einen schwarzen Kaffee getrunken. Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, richtig.
Und danach haben Sie diese Schmerzen bekommen. Okay. Wo genau sind die Schmerzen? Könnten Sie mir zeigen?
Das ist hier Herr Doktor. Kann man sagen Oberbauch. Aber manchmal habe ich ein brennendes Gefühl. Wie Feuer.
Wie Feuer. Okay. Brennend. Und strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus in andere Körperregionen meine ich zum Beispiel in den Hals, in den Unteren. Wie bitte?
Was meine ich strahlen Herr Doktor?
Ich meine in den Rücken oder in anderen Körperregionen wie in den Hals. Nicht ursprünglich Platz, aber diese ziehen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin. Irgendwo hin anders.
Ich habe Schmerzen mit Strahlen in den Hals. Ich habe Saueres Ausstoßen.
Auch Saueres Ausstoßen. Das ist sehr wichtig zu wissen. Vielen Dank für diese wichtige Information.
Man kann sagen in den Hals ausstrahlen.
Okay. Saueres Ausstoßen. Okay. Ja.
Zu den oberen Speiser Rohren. Ja. In den Hals.
Okay. Das habe ich gut verstanden. Danke. Und strahlen Sie oder sind Sie meistens plötzlich oder sind Sie langsam aufgetreten?
Kann man sagen ja plötzlich. Plötzlich.
Und ist das nach dem Verstehen von der Füngepizza. Plötzlich.
Okay. Ist das attackenartig oder sind Sie immer da?
Ja ich habe ähnliche Beschwerden seit ungefähr drei Wochen. Aber leichter. Aber seit gestern Abend ist es ein bisschen schlimmer geworden.
Und ich meine diese Schmerzenattacken dauert diese Schmerzenattacken oder wie lange dauert?
Ich kann nicht so attacken. Aber seit drei Wochen habe ich ähnliche, aber leichte Bauchschmerzen.
Ähnliche, aber leichte.
Wenn ich ein bisschen etwas Fettiges essen oder wenn ich hinlege ist es schlimmer.
Aber wenn ich bei Bedarf Maloxan oder Gaviscon einnehme ist es besser geworden.
Ja gut zu wissen. Ja das habe ich gut verstanden.
Herr Dr. Kotz.
Herr Dr. habe ich zwei Kissen beim Schlafen benutzt und seit drei Wochen das geht besser.
Und wenn ich Hochlagerung von meinem Körper und das geht besser.
Ja das habe ich auch notiert.
Herr Dr. Kotz es tut mir leid dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben.
Aber ich würde gerne wissen wie stark diese Schmerzen sind auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10. Wobei 0 keine Schmerzen und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen bedeutet.
Ungefahren 6.
6. Okay.
Ja 26. Und jetzt momentan leiden Sie darunter oder?
Ja ich habe Oberbauchschmerzen ein bisschen hinter dem Brustbein.
Ja okay.
Und habe ich nur ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen. Können Sie mir helfen Herr Dr.?
Ja natürlich ich bin für Sie da und kümmere mich um Ihre Beschwerden.
Aber wie gesagt soll ich alle wichtigen Informationen zusammen um eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen und um die passende Behandlung für Sie zu planen.
Okay.
Können Sie etwas geben?
Ja deswegen habe ich diese Frage auch gefragt ob Sie momentan auch diese Schmerzen haben.
Und Sie haben bejagt und ich biete Ihnen an eine Schmerzmittel.
Nun brauche ich eine Schmerzmittel.
Ja ja ich habe gerade eben schon gesagt ich biete eine Schmerzmittel.
Aber zuerst soll ich wissen ob Sie eine Schmerzmittel Allergie haben oder eine Medikament Allergie haben.
Ich habe keine Allergie durch irgendwelche Schmerzmittel.
Ich habe Schmerzmittel aber ich habe Schmerzmittel in der Kindheit und ich habe laufende Nasen und tränende Augen.
Manchmal habe ich einen Juckreis und Rötungen und manchmal schwelgen in meinem Mund.
Ja das habe ich verstanden.
Vielen Dank. Das stimmt.
Herr Kotzen Sie haben auch saures Ausstossen und leiden Sie unter einem sauren Geschmack im Mund?
Ja manchmal.
Manchmal?
Drei Wochen.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen? Sie haben Oberbach Schmerzen.
Ich möchte wissen ob Sie Brustschmerzen Atemnot oder Herzrasen haben.
Kann man so sagen. Ich habe eine Schmerzenmischung.
Ich habe eine Schmerzenmischung.
Herr Kotzen schon wieder dran.
Ich bin mit Ihnen imicken.
Ich habe ja eine Brustschmerzenmischung.
Ich habe eine Brustschmerzenmischung.
Ich weiß das gar nicht innenseidlich.
Herr Kotwitz, ich kann nicht gut akustisch verstehen. Könnten Sie das wiederholen?
Ja, aber Herr Doktor, mein Sivilingbruder hatte einen Myokadinfarkt vor 10 Jahren.
Habe ich einen Herzkrank?
Ja, ich überprüfe Ihre Beschwerden. Aber je nach jetzigen, bisherigen Angaben gehe ich nicht davon aus, dass Sie eine Herzkrankheit haben.
Aber ja, ich überprüfe. Und wir werden alle notwendigen Untersuchungen durchführen, um das abzuklären.
Okay, machen Sie sich keine Sorge. Ich kann gut verstehen, dass Sie sich Sorge haben.
Ich erwege, ob ich ein Herzprobleme habe. Aber ich weiß nicht.
Wir werden das überprüfen. Sie haben keine Brustschmerzen oder Herzrasen, nur diese brennende Oberbauchschmerzen in der Halsaustragung.
Und ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie Fieber, Stellfrust, Nachtschweiß oder Kaltenschweiß haben?
Nein.
Kein gut zu wissen. Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit oder Brüchen?
Manchmal, nach der Seele von Fettigkeitsärzten, habe ich ein bisschen Übelkeit oder ...
Nicht momentan, aber manchmal leiden Sie darunter.
Okay.
Aber ich habe niemals gebrochen.
Niemals gebrochen. Okay. Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Kotwets?
Mein Appetit, ja, sehr gut. Ich habe keine Probleme mit meiner Ernährung.
Ernährung, gut zu wissen. Und ich komme zu Ihrem Beschwerden zurück.
Gibt es jemanden, der das gleiche Essen, getrunken, gegessen oder getrunken hat und ähnliche Beschwerden hat?
Meine Frau hat ähnliche Ernährungen benutzt.
Ich habe nur diese Beschwerden gehabt. Andere Personen oder meine Frau oder andere Personen haben keine ähnlichen Beschwerden gehabt.
Okay, das habe ich gut verstanden. Und ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie eine Verletzung am Brustkorb haben?
Nein.
Okay, keine Verletzung. Okay. Und ich möchte wissen, ob Sie Probleme haben mit Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang, ja, ganz normal, Herr Doktor.
Ganz normal. Und wie ...
Und Sie haben viele Fragen gestellt.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage und ich kann das gut verstehen. Aber wie gesagt, am Anfang dieses Gesprächs habe ich gesagt,
alle Informationen sind für uns sehr wichtig, um eine richtige, genaue Diagnose zu stellen, Herr Kotwets. Deswegen muss ich oder soll ich diese Fragen, alle diese Fragen stellen.
Okay, ich bitte um Ihr Verständnis und Geduld. Und leiden Sie Beschwerden mit Wasserlassen?
Ja, überhaupt nicht. Alles ist so gut.
Okay. Haben Sie letztes Mal ungewollt ab oder zugenommen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe meine Gewissprobleme und mein Appetit ist sehr gut und ich möchte alles essen.
Ja, aber die Antwort meiner Frage ...
Keine Gewissverloren.
Keine Gewissverloren oder zugenommen. Okay, das habe ich gut verstanden. Und leiden Sie Schlafprobleme unter Schlafproblemen oder ...
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, wenn ich spätes Essen bekomme, habe ich manchmal Schlafstörungen. Aber sonst ist alles in Ordnung.
Ja, es kann mit Ihren Schlagbeschwerden zusammenhängen. Ich meine die Späternährung, spätes Essen.
Ja.
Und alle Ihre Beschwerden auch.
Herr Kottwitz, gibt es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Zum Beispiel chronische Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck oder erhöhte Blutfettwerte?
Ich verstehe. Seit fünf Jahren habe ich einen Bluthochdruck, aber es ist unter Kontrolle.
Meine nächste Messung vor zwei Tagen war 120 zu 80.
Gute Messung, ja, gute Wert.
Ich meine Stoffwechselstörungen. Aber ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Könnten Sie das wiederholen? Ich konnte nicht gut verstehen. Könnten Sie das wiederholen?
Stoffwechselstörungen.
Ja, akustisch kann ich nicht gut verstehen, Herr Kottwitz.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen. Ist diese Diagnose bei Ihnen gestellt oder?
Ich nehme regelmäßig 40 mg.
Verstanden. Sie leiden unter Fettstoffwechselstörungen.
Ja.
Oder Hyperlipidemie.
Hyperkolesterin oder?
Ja, ja. Hyperkolesterin meinen Sie. Seit wann leiden Sie daran?
Seit zwei Jahren.
Seit zwei Jahren. Okay. Und dagegen nehmen Sie Simvastatin. Wie war die Dosierung von Simvastatin?
40.
Um abend nehmen Sie, ich denke.
Eine Tabletze morgen, aber ich weiß nicht.
Morgen? Okay.
Nicht ich, aber ich weiß nicht.
Ja, ich werde das überprüfen.
Ist das besser am Morgen oder am Abend?
Es wird empfohlen, solche Medikamente besonders im Abend einzunehmen.
Aber wie gesagt werde ich das überprüfen.
Und gegen Bluthochdruck, was für Medikamente nehmen Sie ein oder?
Kandesatins, eine Tablette, morgens.
Die Dosierung habe ich nicht gut verstanden. Könnten Sie das wiederholen?
12 mg.
12 mg. Okay. Milligramm und morgens.
Und diese zwei Medikamente, nehmen Sie irgendwelche anderen Medikamente?
Ja, bei Bedarf nehme ich manchmal Maloxan. Maloxan, okay.
Das hat mir empfohlen. Das geht gut und manchmal Gaviscon. Manchmal nehme ich, ja.
Herr Kottwitz, ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie nach gestern Abend oder gestern diese Medikamente eingenommen haben.
Oder wenn ja, haben Sie dabei Ihnen geholfen?
Nachdem diese Medikamente, ja, ist mein Beschwerden besser geworden.
Besser geworden, aber gestern Abend. Ich meine nach gestern Abend.
Okay, Entschuldigung, Sie haben darüber berichtet. Und um sicher zu sein, habe ich das wiederholt.
Und würden Sie, Akustik kann ich nicht verstehen, Herr Kottwitz.
Wenn Sie bewegen, kann ich nicht gut verstehen.
Ja, gestern Abend habe ich einmal Maloxan und Gaviscon eingenommen. Und ist das ein bisschen besser geworden.
Ja, das habe ich beim Beschwerden notiert, aber danach habe ich das vergessen.
Okay, ja. Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, vor 20 Jahren hatte ich eine blinde Entfernung.
War die Operation komplikationslos?
Es war in Ordnung.
Ja, gut. Noch etwas?
Ich hatte einen Unfall. Nachdem hatte ich eine Gips und Schiene getragen.
Ist das Operation? Aber ich weiß nicht. Ich hatte Mittelhandsknochenbruch.
Ich hatte...
Mittelhandsknochen. Rechts oder links?
Rechts.
Ja. Haben Sie dabei oder währenddessen irgendwelche Betäubungsmittel bekommen?
Nein.
Oder Narkose meine ich.
Höchstwahrscheinlich war das komplikationlos oder wurde das konservativ behandelt.
Das ist nicht eingegangen.
Das Buch hat mein Orthopädie gesagt. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Operation ist.
Ich denke, wie gesagt, höchstwahrscheinlich war das nicht eine Operation. Eine konservative Behandlung.
Leiden Sie unter irgendwelchen Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein. Keine.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben, Herr Kotwitz?
Seit drei Jahren rauche ich ungefähr halbe Packung Zigaretten.
In zehn Zigaretten täglich.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Am Abend drei bis vier Gläser Weißwein.
Ich möchte gern...
Akustik konnte ich nicht gut verstehen.
Drei bis vier.
Drei bis vier. Okay. Weißwein.
Ja. Gläser.
Drei bis vier Gläser Weißwein.
Abends.
Okay. Routiniermäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben.
Ich meine, konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Ich habe keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Okay. Gut.
Und...
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder zu Hause?
Ich bin Polizist.
Ich kann nicht regelmäßig Sport treiben, aber ich muss immer spazieren.
Ich muss immer rausgehen, ja?
Ja, das ist auch schön.
Aber natürlich empfehle ich Ihnen, Bewegung regelmäßig und systematisch zu treiben.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Es wäre besser, wenn Sie Zeit verbringen oder Zeit geben, regelmäßig Sport zu treiben, Herr Gotwitz.
Und Sie sind Polizist. Ich glaube, dass Sie bei der Arbeit Stress haben. Richtig?
Ja. Kann man sagen.
Okay. Sie sind verheiratet und ich möchte wissen, ob Sie Kinder haben?
Ja, ich habe einen Sohn, aber ich bin geschieden.
Aber Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie verheiratet sind.
Ja, früher verheiratet, aber seit Jahren bin ich geschieden.
Okay. Das habe ich notiert. Und Sie sind Polizist.
Jetzt würde ich noch einige Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen. Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, mein Vater und meine Mutter sind noch im Leben.
Aber mein Vater hat Herzprobleme. So kann man sagen, dass die Herzprobleme nicht stören.
Er trägt einen Herzschrittmacher.
Und mein Vater hat Depression und chronische Gastritis und Magenentzündung, hat er gesagt.
Aber mein Zwillingbruder, wie gesagt, hat vor zwei Jahren einen Handherz.
Ja, das habe ich schon notiert.
Was habe ich notiert?
Herr Kotwets, ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit, Verständnis und Ihr Geduld.
Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen ganz fertig.
Laut Ihrer Beschwerde habe ich den Verdacht auf Reflexkrankheit.
Das ist ein Rückfluss von Magensäure in die Speiseröhre.
Das kann zu Entzündung oder Reizbarkeit oder diesen Beschwerden führen.
Okay, aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Deshalb müssen wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, um das zu bestätigen.
Zunächst werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Anschließend Ihnen Blut für das Labor abnehmen und einen EKG.
Ich werde einen EKG schreiben, um eine mögliche Herzursache auszuschließen.
Danach werde ich eine Bauchultraschall durchführen.
Und gegebenenfalls kann eine Magenspiegelung erforderlich sein.
Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Herr Doktor, ich vertraue aber nicht Ultraschall.
Und früher hat unser Gynäkologen schon gesagt, dass ich eine Töchter bekommen habe.
Aber ich hatte einen Sohn.
Ist das richtige Verfahren, persönlich Ultraschall?
Ich kann Ihre Bedenken gut verstehen, Herr Kotwets.
Aber die Medizin oder besonders solche Diagnostikmethoden entwickeln sich im Laufe der Zeit.
Vielleicht haben Sie diese Erfahrung vor Jahren erlebt.
Natürlich, jeden Tag entwickeln sich die Medizin oder entwickeln sich alle.
Z.B. die Töchter oder die künstliche Intelligenz.
Wir erleben jeden Tag immer Neues.
Aber wie gesagt, das kann ich gut verstehen.
Sie sind in guten Händen. Sie können uns einfach vertrauen.
Wir werden alle notwendigen Untersuchungen für Sie durchführen.
Sobald Ihre Befunde voll liegen, beschiebe ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es weitergeht.
Sie können hier bleiben und auf mich warten. Ich komme gleich.
Danke schön.
Guten Morgen. Ich bin Frau Müller. Frau Hasen, Natriumwert 168 mmol pro Liter.
Frau Hansen.
Könnten Sie das vorstellen?
Gerne.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen. Ich kümmere mich um Sie.
Danke. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Herzlich willkommen, Herr Dau. Können Sie sich kurz vorstellen?
Frau Oberarztin, ich heiße Cetin Duan. Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit etwa mehr als zwei und halb Jahren bin ich in Deutschland mit meiner ganzen Familie.
Mit Deutsch lernen habe ich tatsächlich erst nach meiner Ankunft hier begonnen.
Bis jetzt habe ich versucht, intensiv Deutsch zu lernen und auf meine Berufskennnisse zu erfüllen oder Fortbildung teilzunehmen.
Jetzt bin ich für diese Prüfung hier.
Okay. Wann haben Sie Ihr Medizinstudium absolviert?
Mein Medizinstudium habe ich 2009 an der Universität Istanbul-Cerapace abgeschlossen.
Danach habe ich als Assistentarzt in Pathologie zwei Jahre lang und in der inneren Medizinabteilung vier Jahre lang gearbeitet.
Im Jahr 2017 musste ich aus politischen Gründen meine Stelle an der Universität verlassen.
Bis 2023 habe ich als Allgemeinarzt in der Notaufnahme gearbeitet.
Weil ich die Lebensbedingungen in der Türkei als unsicher und schwierig empfinde, habe ich mich entschieden, nach Deutschland zu kommen.
Okay, verstehe. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Frau Berstin, ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstelle, muss ich etwas Wichtiges Ihnen mitteilen.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, dass Herr Assen einen Natriumwert von 168 Millimol pro Liter hat.
Dieser Wert ist stark erhöht und spielt Hypernatriämie.
Okay. Was ist der Ursache für Hypernatriämie?
Vielleicht für diese Partei, für allgemeine Informationen meinen Sie.
Für Hypernatriämie?
Ja, für Hypernatriämie. Das habe ich verstanden.
Wir können einfach sagen, dass es relativ über die Wasserverlust geht.
Wo durch?
Endstate.
Endstate, ja.
Wasserverlust.
Ja, wir haben nichts.
Die häufigste Ursache ist natürlich Wasserverlust wie Erbrechen, Hyperhydrose oder Amnesis durch Diaro oder Hyperhydrose.
Die kann das auch führen.
Und auch die Uretika wie Osmolische oder Schleife.
Können Sie ein Beispiel geben? Schleife-Diuretika?
Ja, natürlich. Tolazemit oder Frosemit kann ich einfach sagen.
Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Hypernatriämie?
Besonders neurologische Symptome erwarten wir bei Hypernatriämie.
Warum entstehen neurologische Symptome bei Hypernatriämie?
Weil Natrium sehr wichtig ist für die Gehirn- oder Nervzellenstabilität.
Nein, Gehirn. Diese ausführliche Erklärung kann ich nicht machen.
Deswegen bin ich aufgehört. Ich habe aufgehört, dazu zu erzählen.
Vielleicht Gehirn. Die Elektrolyth-Haushaltung ist die richtige.
Oder gleich geht es. Ich habe nicht die richtige Worte.
Ich habe mich nicht daran erinnert.
Elektrolyth-Haushalt im Zentral- oder Nervensystem sind sehr wichtig.
Besonders die Natrium-Gleichwert ist auch wichtig.
Beide Situationen, egal ob Natrium erhöht oder niedrig,
können viele neurologische Symptome verursachen.
Wie zum Beispiel. Oder es kann eine Orientierungstörung geben.
Oder auch... Ich versuche es komplizierter zu erklären.
Aber das kann ich nicht machen.
Hypernatriämie kann eine Nervzellen-Schrumpfung verursachen.
Ja, diese Worte.
Dann kann die neurologische Ausfälle entstehen.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm. Sie konnten einfach erklären.
Natrium-Spiegel ist sehr wichtig im Gehirn- und Nerven-Zell.
Elektrolyth-Haushalt ist sehr wichtig im Nerven-Zell.
Ja, das ist auch sehr wichtig.
Ok. Wie können Sie die Hypernatriämie behandeln?
Es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen den Arten der Hypernatriämie.
Aber der wichtigste Punkt oder Kernpunkt in der Behandlung der Hypernatriämie ist
sofort aber langsam Korrektur.
Warum langsam?
Um die möglichen Gehirnödem zu vermeiden, müssen wir langsam korrigieren.
Ich meine, mit Korrigieren die erhöhten Werte zu senken oder zu reduzieren zu lassen.
Dadurch sollten wir zuerst die isovolumische Hochsalzlösung
dann gegebenenfalls, oder je nach Werte, je nach Volumenlücke, oder wie kann man sagen,
Volumengeb, meine ich, oder Wassermangel.
Ok. Ich habe auch gehört, das Erklären.
Je nach den Arten der Hypernatriämie können wir auf jeden Fall Natrium sofort aber langsam korrigieren.
Soll ich weiter machen oder soll ich versuchen weiter zu machen?
Sie können versuchen weiter zu machen.
Zuerst aber nehmen Sie ein Tief ein.
Zuerst brauchen Sie ein bisschen entspannen ruhig zu bleiben.
Sie wissen alle und ich kann ganz klar verstehen.
Nach dem Entspannen können Sie alles erklären.
Ich habe tief eingeatmet und jetzt kann ich auch weiter machen.
Wie gesagt, ist der wichtigste Punkt dabei, langsam Korrektur.
Langsam Korrektur meine ich, zum Beispiel pro Tag 10 oder 20 Minimal Natrium zu reduzieren.
Oder in einer Stunde halbe Minimal Natrium zu reduzieren.
Damit oder dazu sollten wir zuerst, je nach Volumen oder Natrium Spiegel,
zuerst isovolemische, danach gegebenenfalls sollten wir auch weniger prozentige Kohlsatzlösungen verabreichen.
Ok. Was haben Sie noch?
Wie gesagt, ich habe einen neuen Patienten in der Natuafnahme aufgenommen.
Es geht um Herrn Jürgen Kotwets.
Er ist 46 Jahre alt und geboren am 22.06.1980.
Er ist 1,91 Meter groß und wiegt 95 Kilo.
Er kam heute zu uns wegen seit gestern Abend bestehender Oberbauchschmerzen.
Laut der Erzeuge des Patienten sind die Schmerzen plötzlich nach dem Essen und Trinken aufgetreten.
Er berichtet, dass diese Schmerzen in den Hals ausstrahlen.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen drängend.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 von 10.
Die Schmerzen verschlimmen sich beim Hinlegen oder nach dem fertigen Essen,
während sie sich bei Oberkörperhochlagerung oder nach Einnahme von Gaviscon oder Maloxan verbessern.
Was ist Maloxan?
Maloxan ist ein Kaumtablet. Es ist ein Antacid.
Damit kann die Magensäure neutralisiert werden.
Was enthält Maloxan?
Welche hat Wirkstoffeinheit?
Wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Proterat in Deutschland ist,
Wahrscheinlich gibt es darin ein Magnesiumstoff.
Es ist einfach Magnesium. Magnesium Salz vielleicht.
Magnesium Hydroxid.
Magnesium und Aluminium Hydroxid.
Magnesium Hydroxid und Aluminium Hydroxid.
Vielen Dank für diese Information, Frau Oberastin.
Außerdem erwähnte er, dass er seit 3 Wochen ähnliche, aber leichtere Beschwerden hat.
War er deswegen beim Hausarzt?
Nein, diese Frage wurde verneint.
Nicht in gut Kontakt setzen.
Wer hat Ihnen Maloxan und Gaviscon empfohlen?
Hat er einfach bei der Apotheke gekauft?
Ich denke, kann man einfach bei der Apotheke erhalten.
Oder? Ich weiß es nicht.
Meine Frage für diese Patienten.
Haben Sie keine Frage?
Nein, diese Frage wurde nicht gestellt.
Begleitend klagt er manchmal über Übelkeit und saures Ausstossen.
Und auch sauren Geschmack im Mund.
Diese Beschwerden wurden von den Patienten berichtet.
Vegetative anamnestisch ergab sich schmerzbedingte Lysomnie.
Der Patient leidet seit 5 Jahren an arterieller Hypertonie.
Seit 3 oder 5 Jahren an einer Hyperkolesterenomie.
Dagegen nimmt er 12 mg Kandesartan morgens.
40 mg Simvastatin.
Einmal morgens täglich.
Und wie gesagt nimmt er bei Bedarf Maloxan und Gaviscon ein.
Er hat Fullenallergie.
Die sich durch Rhinokonjunktivitis und Eruthem äußert.
Bei der Nutzanamnese berichtete er über einen Nikotinkonsum.
1,5 Packjahrs.
Und so wie den Konsum von 3 bis 4 Gläser Weißwein.
1,5 Packjahrs?
1,5 Packjahrs.
Ich meine 1,5 Packjahrs.
Seit 3 Jahren 10 Zigaretten.
Bevor hat er nicht gerauft.
Nur seit 3 Jahren.
Er hat so berichtet.
Sie haben einfach gebraucht.
Seit wann?
Meine zweite Frage war ob sie früher geraucht haben.
Deswegen habe ich diese Antwort ausreichend gefunden.
Und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Bei der Arbeit hatte er Stress.
Leider treibe ich nicht Sport.
Die Familie an Amnese ergab eine Herz-Rhythmus-Störung bei dem Vater.
Und Depressionen.
Eine chronische Gastritis bei der Mutter.
Er hatte einen Zivilen Bruder.
Oder einfach ein Myokart.
Er ist an Myokart-Infarktus vor 2 Jahren verstorben.
Sozial- und amnestisch ist er geschieden.
Hat einen Sohn. Er ist Polizist.
Was ist Ihre Verdacht?
Nach Angaben des Patienten habe ich Verdacht auf eine gastroesophagiale Reflexkrankheit.
Dafür sprechen eine brennende Retro-Sternale und in den Hals auszutrahlen.
Nach Einnahme von Antacid eine signifikante Linderung.
Und bei der Oberkörperkochleger-Lagerung eine Linderung.
Mit fertigem Essen oder spätem Essen oder Schlafen.
Hinlegen sofort malzeitig oder fertigem Essen eine Verschlechterung.
Solche Zeichen oder Befunde sprechen dafür.
Welchen Faktor hat der Patient für eine gastroesophagiale Reflexkrankheit?
Er trinkt Alkohol und raucht.
Er beachtet nicht die gesunde Ernährung oder die ausgehobene Ernährung.
Die Lebensstilung des Patienten passt dazu.
Und auch Männergeschlecht kann sein.
Nicht über Gewicht.
Und er hat Stress bei der Arbeit?
Stress bei der Arbeit ist auch wichtig für diese Verdachtsdiagnose.
Aber Medikamentöschen habe ich nicht einen Grund gefunden oder beobachtet.
Welche Differentialdiagnose kommen in Betracht?
Differentialdiagnose kommen an akutes Coronasyndrom und auch vielleicht Magenkarzinom in Betracht.
Obwohl er keine Gewichtsverguss oder andere Besymptome oder Familienbelastung hat.
Deswegen wäre es auch Gatschitis oder Ullkussverdrückung.
Oder Gatschitis.
Gatschitis ist besser, weil es auch eine familiäre Belastung gibt bei der Mutter.
Ich muss diese Differentialdiagnose verändern.
Vielen Dank für die Empfehlung.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Das ist nicht schlimm. Sie können einfach sehr gut erklären, warum Sie einem Magenkarzinom daran denken und hasst.
Obwohl er ein paar Symptome nicht hat.
Hauptsache ist, über Ihre Meinung zu sprechen.
Hoffentlich.
Aber ich muss natürlich weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Bitte schön.
Um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich nun natürlich diesen Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Und Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Es ist sehr wichtig, einen EKG zu schreiben, um eine mögliche Herzkardialursache auszuschlissen.
Darüber hinaus werde ich einen Bauch-Zone-Abdomen durchführen.
Und gegebenenfalls kann eine Oesophagastrodendonskopie oder ÖGD erforderlich sein bei diesem Patienten.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Lebe- und Nierenwerte, Elektrolyte und auch Herzmuskelenzymen,
Blutensimen bestimmen lassen.
Auch weil der Patient, ja, Hypocholestin, ein Lipidprofil bestimmen lässt.
Ja, diese Laborparameter.
Weil bis jetzt eine von meinen Verdachtsdiagnosen ulkosventrökul ist, werde ich im Labor auch fechale, okkulte Bluttests kontrollieren lassen.
Sie können auch bei Gastro- oder Fägerreflüge kranken.
Ja, natürlich. Sie haben recht.
Er hat keine Beschwerden beim Stuhlgang, aber trotzdem können Sie ihn übernehmen.
Ok, wie können Sie den Patienten behandeln?
Ja, natürlich sollte sich die Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich diese Patientin anschauen.
Es gibt eine, ja, scheinbar Ambulanzbehandlung.
Bei diesem Fall ist die wichtigste, oder ist die wichtigste Lebensstelländerung.
Diese Änderung ist wichtiger als Medikamentösertherapie und Patientenschulung.
Ich finde, diese Patientin braucht aus einer Patientenschulung.
Was möchte ich heute mit Patientenschulungen?
Oder was möchten Sie dieser Patienten empfehlen?
Ja, ich empfehle ihm, diesen Patienten Gewicht zu reduzieren, ausgewogene und gesunde Ernährung zu beachten,
die Eingekleidung zu vermeiden und mit Alkohol und Nikotinkonsum aufzuhören.
Ja, für diese Patientin empfehle ich ihn.
Wann ist er die Mahlzeit?
Ja, natürlich, die spätere Mahlzeit zu vermeiden auch.
Und kleine Portionen.
Ja, auch kleine Menge, kleine Portionen zu ernähren, empfehle ich.
Ich empfehle diese Punkte oder dem Patienten.
Und Medikamentöser, Entschuldigung, bitte schön.
Ja, bitte schön.
Diese Empfehlungen sind am wichtigsten.
Danach braucht diese Patientin natürlich Medikamentösertherapie.
Ich würde Medikamentöser, Protonpompen, Hämmer und Antaizide verordnen.
Aber regelmäßig und an passende Nutzung, nicht bei Bedarf, besonders bei akuten.
Ich empfehle regelmäßig oder ich würde Protonpompen, Hämmer und Antaizide verschreiben.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Können Sie Magenspiegelung erklären oder wie können Sie die Patienten Magenspiegelung erklären?
Okay, für die Patienten meinen Sie.
Magenspiegelung ist eine Untersuchung mit der wir die hohlen Organe von innen beobachten oder untersuchen.
Dazu führen wir einen Schlauch mit der Kamera durch den Mund ein.
Wir geben Ihnen ein Betäubungsmittel damit Sie nichts spüren.
Wir können auch dabei während dieser Untersuchung kleine Gewerbeprobe entnehmen.
Damit wir, um eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ungefähr 30 Minuten.
Wir empfehlen Ihnen danach kein Autofahren oder Tätigkeiten, die Aufmerksamkeit brauchen, nicht auszuüben.
Okay, das ist genug. Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Doan.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Wir haben ein paar Anfälle.
Ich habe schon gefragt.
Daher muss ich nichts sagen.
Okay.
Dann benutzt man die V-Gesakt sehr.
Man kann es ein paar Mal benutzen.
Aber wie ich es vorhin gesagt habe, muss man es nicht sehr benutzen.
Man kann es auch noch einmal sagen.
Oder man kann es auch noch einmal mit der Gesichtseinheit und der Mimik zeigen.
Ich sage das für den einen.
Das dauert viel Zeit.
Man kann es auch schwer machen, die Zeit zu verbringen.
Und du hast auch oft das Okay benutzt.
Ich habe es bemerkt.
Ich versuche es anzunehmen, aber es hat nicht funktioniert.
Das Okay benutze ich sehr.
Aber wenn man etwas nicht gut macht, kann man es manchmal falsch verstanden sein.
Wenn man viel Alkohol hat, hat man es nicht gut gemacht.
Das ist so.
Man hat viel Alkohol, aber es ist okay.
Man kann es nicht gut machen, wenn man etwas nicht gut macht.
Das war es.
Ich bin auf der 1. Karte.
Ich würde es besser, wenn Sie eine Reaktion geben.
Ich habe immer 4 Kade Scharapf.
Ich habe es vergessen.
Man muss eine große Reaktion geben.
So etwas wie ...
Das ist es.
Das ist nicht gut für unsere Gesundheit.
Das ist schon ein Problem.
Wenn man das aufweset, ist es nicht gut.
Das ist okay.
Das ist ein unfassbares Problem.
Wenn man schon viel Reaktionen gemacht hat,
dann kann man es nicht mehr machen.
Das ist nicht nötig.
Das ist ein Problem.
Und?
Man sollte sich nie auf die moralische Motivationen nicht ausdenken.
Wenn man sehr gut spricht, etwas nicht sagt,
dann muss man es nicht aufgeben.
Man muss es nicht aufgeben.
Man kann es auch aus dem Anfang sagen.
Oder man kann es nicht aufgeben.
Man geht sehr fest.
Man versucht, das Wort zu finden.
Das hat viel Zeit verpasst.
Das hat die Stimme verpasst.
Ich hoffe.
Sie versuchen, schöne Worte zu benutzen.
Sie versuchen, die Worte auf der gleichen Art zu sprechen.
Sie versuchen, sich zu bewegen.
Das ist gut.
Aber die Worte sind wenig.
Es ist wichtig, die Worte zu sprechen.
Deswegen sollte man versuchen,
die Worte zu bewegen.
Die Worte.
Danke.
Die Fragen, die Beziehung, die Beziehung, die Beziehung,
die Beziehung, die Beziehung, die Beziehung,
die Beziehung, die Beziehung, die Beziehung, die Beziehung.
Die Beziehung, den Beziehung, die Beziehung.
Das kann man so auch nennen.
Das ist so.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen Gute.
Tschüss.